salut c'est Lucas brut nature les
pythons les cobras les crocodiles ça
peut faire peur et quand des
particuliers les détiennent sans
autorisation ou les abandonn on sait pas
trop quoi en faire ces animaux c'est la
passion de Philippe gilet défendre un
bébé Fox c'est facile c'est mignon mais
défendre un vilain serpent un scorpion
une mégale ou une araignée c'est
difficile c'est un sacré boulot des
animaux comme ça Philippe en a plus de
400 chez lui et son mantra c'est
apprendre à mieux les connaître pour ne
plus en avoir peur ça va Ali he ah mon
bébé comment tu vas mon bébé
oui bonjour mon bébé et aller rentre
dans ta maison ouis tu veux que je te
porte peut-être c'est ça espèce de
faignamb hein voilà et là ça veut dire
il va dormir tranquillement dans son
coin et maintenant si je lui parle il va
m'engueuler regarde bien qu'est-ce qu'il
y a tu vas dormir hein tu vas dormir
ouais
ouais c'est pas bien
ça cette semaine c'est un épisode un peu
spécial de la grande explication
clémentine est allée chez Philippe pour
découvrir sa vie avec ces animaux là et
Clémentine elle les reptiles elle en a
vraiment vraiment peur vous verrez tu
risques rien tu va pas me mordre mais
non mais non mais non et alors
d'ailleurs on retrouvera Clémentine en
fin de vidéo pour débriefer avec elle
les coulisses du reportage sur place
elle s'est demandé pourquoi avoir autant
de reptiles chez soi et comment on vit
avec ses animaux on vous
explique VO là elle aime pas quand je
suis là non tu fais pas l'idiote arrête
Adriana tu arrêtes ton cinéma arrête
doucement
oui il y a quelqu'un qui est là et alors
Adriana doucement doucement s'il te
plaît doucement tu arrêtes un peu tu
arrêtes un peu voilà arrête un peu
couche-toi doucement Adriana calme-toi
hein voilà tu te calmes alors ici tu as
par exemple des des gros pyons va jouer
ailleurs allez file
file allez va jouer ailleurs allez
rentre cheztoi et maintenant tu vas me
faire le plaisir de lancer toucher ta
main et de toucher ça vas-y vas-y tu
peux le tenir d'une main touche-le comme
ça touche-le ça c'est une première ouais
ça je te J ça ça m'angoisse beaucoup le
contact ça m'angoisse ah non faut pas
regarde c'est tout doux et encore lui tu
vois il a besoin de se se mouiller un
petit peu non mais bravo tu as touché un
des serpents les plus longs du monde ce
sont les réticulés c'est les plus grands
et les plus longs mais tu es en sécurité
parce que la tête est de l'autre côté
oui c'est ça voilà bah oui on fait pas
n'importe quoi quand même c'est un
espace qui a pas l'air très grand comme
ça est-ce que ça leur suffit il faut
savoir que dans la nature quand un
serpent il n'est pas comme une antilope
ou un lion ou un buffle ou un chat dans
un appartement qui a besoin d' bout de
jardin qui délimiter des des des
territoires et courir un chpent ça mange
et ça va dans un trou ça peut rester un
mois dans le même trou un pyon ça pas
besoin de se dépenser ou de se pourquoi
il se déplace un pyon à votre avis pour
chasser un charpent pourquoi chasser
pour chercher à manger pas pour attaquer
pour chercher à manger pour se nourrir
s'il a un endroit où il peut dormir une
vipère française pendant 30 ans vit à
peu près 30 ans s'il y a toujours des
souris dans le coin elle sera là toute
sa vie elle en bougera pas vous la
verrez tous les ans vous pourrez la voir
au même endroit parce que parelle pas
s'il y a plus de nourriture elle va être
obligée de se déplacer au risque de se
faire attraper par un oiseau par un
prédateur ou de prendre un coup de pelle
entre autre donc il va falloir faire
très attention pour trouver un nouvel
endroit puis le nouvel endroit qu'elle
va trouver il y aura peut-être il sera
déjà habité par un autre il va falloir
se battre pour retrouver un autre
endroit c'est pas facile voyez faut bien
comprendre ce qui se passe dans la
nature eux alors ils sont nourris avec
du poulet ça fait 23 ans qu'on récupère
les nourritures qui sont rejeté par les
hommes voilà des gros serpents c'est ça
qui Mang parce que tu vois la date est
passée la loi oblige à l'enlever et les
enfants pe pas le manger mais nous nous
enaca c'est
recycler c'est poulets qu'on récupère
chacun va en manger six pendant l'été et
tout l'hiver ils mangeront plus rien ils
seront coiner dans un petit trou ils
font leur hibernation ils bougont plus
ils viennent dou C CHP chez des chez
quelqu'un qui les élevait entre autres
qui en élevait quelques-uns bah il avait
pas les autorisations administratives il
av pas tout ça et au lieu de rester
discret bah il s'est fait attraper par
l'administration qui a saisi les animaux
parce que c'est les animaux très très
dangereux faut savoir quand même c'est
des animaux qui peuvent aouffer très
rapidement donc ils font partie des
espèces dangereuses alors ce petit iquan
il vient de kurou kurou c'est la guyan
et comment se fait-il que cette faune de
Guyane qui est protégée soit arrivée
chez moi ben simplement c'est qu'il
arrive quand vous savez les containers
en guyan qui remplissent des bananes et
des choses choses comme ça le containur
reste là les gens travaillent et puis
quand c'est midi c'est l'heure de la
pause ils laissent les containurs
ouverts ils vont manger quand ils
reviennent une heure après bah il y a un
petit Tiguan qui est rentré dedans pour
manger les bananes eux il referment le
conur il regarde pas il arrive en France
on m'appelle entre autres je vais à
l'aéroport on regarde dans les les
containers qui sont arrivés les gars en
on vu un on le récupère et on le puce on
le met en règle moi je suis capacitaire
évidemment tout reptiles plus les
amphibiens plus les évenimeux plus les
arthropodes bon c'est une grosse
capacité présentation publique mobile
c'est mon établissement je peux me
déplacer sur toute la France en règle
avec un véhicule qui transporte ses
animaux en règle j'ai le droit de le
faire il y a personne il y a aucun
refuge pour les récupérer qui va les
récupérer il y a pas les autorisations
alors qu'est-ce qu'on fait va les tuer
mais on a pas le droit de les tuer alors
qu'est-ce qu'ils font les gens parce que
un animal qu'on a élevé pendant 2 ans
même si c'est la pire vipère B on lui
rend la liberté et là on arrive sur une
pollution écologique grave viens
là doucement stop stop
tiens il l' attrapé quand même doucement
tiens mais tu es un goinfre alors tu
vois évidemment quand il s'agit de
manger ça rigole pas ah bah là oui he
bon tu crois pas que tu as assez mangé
gringo alors comme il a chaud soit il
rentre dans son bassin qui est là
soit ben il reste là et demain matin il
ressortira il ira de toute la journée
dans le jardin et le soir il rentre bon
là il a mangé il rentre Philiipe g c'est
qui c'est un personnage qui a eu la
chance d'avoir vécu 30 ans de vie 30 ans
de ma vie en Afrique centrale en
République centrafricaine exactement et
quand j'étais gamin donc ma playstation
à moi c'était pas j'en avais pas
télévision on n' avait pas donc mon
plaisir à moi c'était de courir dans la
brousse d'être avec les Africains autour
du feu le soir d'aller voir les pigmets
d' d'être avec eux de chasser avec eux
et c'est eux qui m'ont appris toutes les
petites choses qu'on connaît pas parce
que nos mélanges de de de de
connaissance c'est ça notre vraie
richesse j'avais des Scorpions des
serpents des lézards des petites
antilopes je les élevais au biberon je
c'était c'était j'étais trempé dedans ça
m'a toujours passionné et évidemment la
nature les arbres les plantes et
évidemment les serpents pourquoi parce
que les antilopes les lions les
éléphants bah c'est un peu comme quand
vous allez en Bretagne vous voyez des
vaches a rien d'étonnant mais par contre
les serpents ils sont toujours cachés
ils vis dans des trous on les voit
jamais il faut aller à certaines heures
il faut aller les déloger et donc
évidemment on va chercher toujours ce
qui est le plus compliqué ici on va
rentrer dans la salle des animaux
dangereux donc des venimeus qu'on
appelle he évidment c'est fermé à clé
c'est sécurisé voilà tiens viens
suis-moi alors ici voilà tu as des des
vipères des cobras alors tu vois on a
des grandes places pour les vipères mais
elle panique un petit peu par exemple
c'est trop grand celuià il est au taqué
là voilà alors il faut savoir si un
animal oui il peut tuer l'homme bien sûr
mais son venin peut aussi soigner les
hommes là c'est les bois là aussi tu as
encore des bois tu vois des pythons et
cetera et là tu as des couleuvre et là
on peut te sortir une couleœuvre on va
faire uneexpérience tous les deux toi tu
aimes pas trop ça tu peux le dire ouais
ben je vais te montrer un serpent qui
est très très joli d'abord qui est un
vrai bijou ben je vais te le montrer il
est ici écoute-moi ouais regarde
donne-moi ton bras comme ça non non mais
je te montre un truc si je te prends
comme ça tu vois il y a prédation h si
je te soulève comme ça il y a douceur
alors mets tes doigts comme ça
simplement tes doigts et je vais le
poser sur tes mains le fais pas tomber
rien non non tu risques rien il va pas
mordre mais non mais non mais non et
alors attends déjà le contends alors
respire écoute-moi fais-moi plaisir
écoute-moi respire à
fond allez enlève tout ça
décompresse ça va et maintenant tu vas
carrément comme un s en parachute PRS
voilà regarde regarde regarde non non
non non regarde-moi non il va pas aller
loin t'inquiète pas tu sais ce que tu
fais c'est hyper courageux parce que tu
as vraiment une petite phobie maintenant
tu laisses courir sur ta main laisse
courir sur tes mains mets tes mains tend
les simplement laisse faire coule coule
détends-toi regarde-moi regarde-moi
regarde regarde regarde la tête voilà
détends-toi tu sais ce que tu fais c'est
hyper courageux tu sais que dans les
Forces Spéciales on fait faire des des
trucs comme ça pour que les hommes
aillent plus loin et M les choses plus
loin bon voilà maintenant regarde-moi
pense à autre chose bah tu peux leur
dire qu'est-ce que tu en penses dis-leur
ah c'est très j'avoue c'est je
m'attendais pas à être capable de ça et
ben si on peut le
faire
pu tu avais quelqu'un qui connais
d'accord donc il va essayer de
t'accompagner le mieux possible mais les
90 % du boulot qui sont fait c'est par
le toit parce que tu tu acceptes le truc
quelqu'un qui n'a pas peur c'est
quelqu'un qui est inconscient moi j'ai
peur mais je contrôle ma peur par la
connaissance maintenant laisse faire tu
vas voir regarde tu vas rien voir tu vas
regarde regarde enlè enlève ta main
regarde et maintenant je vais te montrer
quelque chose magique tiens ét la
lumière quoi quoi quo regarde regarde
avec une lumière noire regarde regarde
il change de couleur c'est ouf ah tu
vois tu as plus peur là tu as plus peur
tu vois regarde c'est le seul aracnide
parce que c'est la famille des aracnid
c'est le seul qui est capable de changer
de couleur non non non il ira pas plus
loin regarde je suis devenu in génieur
conseil dans le vivant à la à la Cité
des Sciences à la Villette à Paris et on
avait fait les terrariums
extraordinaires magnifiques et tout et
on les gens plus pour se faire peur je
comprenais pas apprenons c'est bien
d'apprendre et c'est comme ça que j'ai
décidé de créer un jour l'association
imphone information sur la faune en
abrégé j'ai créé cette association et
j'ai dit il faut montrer au français que
ces animaux sont pas des horribles
choses qui font peur mais simplement des
animaux à part entière qui ont le droit
de citer sur la planète comme on en a
vit en Afrique et on doit les connaître
vous savez un animal quand vous le
connaissez vous rentrez dans son
intimité ça devient un animal mais quand
vous voyez une araignée c'est horrible
toi-même qui m'interview en ce moment tu
as été d'une d'un courage exceptionnel
tu risques rien du tout tu as pris un
serpent dans tes mains tu en avais peur
Migal les scorpion dans tes mains et
maintenant vois ce que la victoire que
tu as remporté sur toi-même et te dire
finalement c'est vraiment des animaux
c'est pas des horribles choses c'est pas
des monstres regarde en face de toi et
dealer brut c'est comme ça dealer ah
ouais et ça c'est le but de
l'association c'est Mar ah oui il a la
langue toute bleue c'est rigolo oui
alors ça c'est un truc encore très
particulier les animaux voient les uvet
donc quand ils voit une langue bleue
avec des uvet ben ils ont l'impression
qu'ils vont prendre des uvet c'est pas
bon c'est une défense faut que ce soit
abordable même pour les enfants et que
tout le monde comprenne hop tout de
suite tu vois je Chouffe de l'air chaud
grâce à ces petites faussettes
thermiques
regarde tu vois il tire la langue tout
de suite pour savoir ce que c'est il
sent la chaleur il est prêt à taper ça
c'est très dangereux ça c'est pas très
dangereux mais c'est dangereux c'est
c'est un venimeux nos animaux qu'on
récupère on les appelle les ambassadeurs
il sont là pour représenter leur espèce
et montrer aux enfants qu'ils existent
si tu veux passer il faut venir là je
suis pas très ça va al he he mon bébé
comment tu vas mon bébé
oui bonjour mon bébé bonjour mon bébé ça
va mon gâur qu'est-ce que tu racontes
hein tu vois des marques dans le salon
par terre tu vois des petites marques
parce que quand ils mangent ils
attrapent un bout de poulet quel fois il
racle un peu bon c'est pas grave ça fait
partie du jeu ils sont mignons comme
tout il ferme les yeux tu fermes les
yeux à lit il faut être en contact avec
les animaux tout doucement s'en
approcher lentement avec calme et
tranquillité et vous en faites des
copains c'est tout c'est tout bête
attant quand ils ont très faim ils vont
pas manger de l'homme ils en ont pas
mangé c'est pas leur truc parce qu'il y
en a qui aiment les souris d'autres qui
aiment les rat d'autres ils ont un goût
différent les seuls animaux qui
attaquent ce sont les animaux blessés
oou les femelles qui ont des bébés ou
alors que vous avez violé leur
territoire à ce moment-là ils vont
tendance à vous faire partir si vous
partez pas ils vont vous rentrer dedans
mais ils n'attaquent pas ils défendent
quelque chose remarquez ça dans la
nature et si vous allez doucement parce
que eux ils ont le temps ils prennent le
temps de vivre nous on a une
montre on regarde partout on peut pas
s'entendre avec la nature de temps en
temps il faut prendre le temps le temps
de regarder la nature parce que c'est
magnifique ce que nous offre cette
planète ça va hein on est en train de
voir pourà depuis un moment de monter un
vrai un vrai refuge un refuge national
pour ces animaux on en a pas on a des
interdictions des lois mais on a pas de
refuge on a rien on a pour les chiens
pour les chats et en plus c'est c'est
dur autant prendre des gens qui les
aiment et qui sont passionnés pour s'en
occuper monter un refuge national qui du
dans le temps parce que je vais vous
dire quelque chose entre nous je
considère la terre comme un toilette
publique des chotes publiqu on va parler
clair pourquoi des chotes public parce
que si on est bien éduqué quand on
rentre dans ces toilettes on est censé
les laisser aussi propres quand on
rentre que quand on en sort si on est
bien éduqué et bien la terre c'est
devenu un chot public parce que quand on
arrive sur la terre quand on en repart
on l'a bien s par contre moi ce que je
voudrais faire parce que moi aussi j'ai
aidé à salir comme tout le monde
j'aimerais bien laisser un truc propre
derrière moi avant de partir et de de
laisser pour la France un endroit où on
puisse récupérer tous ces animaux qui se
baladent et les laisser vivre
tranquillement de leur côté et ne pas
embêter les humains qui finissent par
les tuer voilà c'est ce que j'aimerais
laisser quelque chose de propre sur
cette planète qu'est-ce qu'il y a hein
qu'est-ce que vous faites là mais c'est
elle qui nous garde les crocodiles quand
il quun s'approche il préviennentou on
pas besoin de sonnette d'ailleurs si tu
demandes aux gens de l'association
qu'est-ce qui est le plus dangereux ici
les
oies salut Clémentine salut Lucas en
regardant ton reportage je s posé plein
de questions et je pense c'est cool si
on peut en parler ensemble là toi je
crois que tu étais pas trop trop à
l'aise avec ces animaux les reptiles
comment ça s'est passé tu as ressenti
quoi pendant le tournage bah c'est vrai
que moi les les reptiles enfin moi je
pensais être phobique des serpents je
t'avoue même que en arrivant à la gare
le midi avant d'aller au tournage j'ai
même eu un petit moment où je me suis
dit mais qu'est-ce que je suis en train
de faire est-ce qu'on est vraiment sûr
de cette idée et puis en fait ce
tournage ça a été assez fou en vrai ça a
été vraiment une expérience et en fait
ce qui est assez dingue c'est qu'après
ce tournage ça a vraiment provoquer un
espèce de déclic moi chez moi où ça même
dans des situations personnelles ça m'a
permis de dépasser C certaines barrières
mentales que je pouvais avoir juste du
simple fait d'avoir réussi à faire des
choses comme ça quoi tous ces animaux
qu'on voit dans la vidéo il y en a il y
en a plein d'où ils viennent alors c'est
un petit peu expliqué déjà dans le
reportage mais évidemment on pouvait pas
mettre tous les tous les tous les tous
les exemples qu'on avait là-bas il y en
a qui sont relâchés dans la nature par
des gens qui prennent par exemple une
grosse tortue ou un cobra chez eux enfin
peut-être pas un cobra c'est un cas un
peu extrême mais qui prennent un serpent
chez eux qui en fait au bout d'un moment
se rendent compte que c'est plus
d'entretien que ce qu'il pensaient du
coup ils vont les relâcher parce qu'ils
ont pas envie de les tuer tu peux avoir
aussi des cas avec des saisies avec des
gens qui ont pas les autorisations pour
détenir ce genre d'animaux et puis des
cas de maltraitance aussi et puis tu as
aussi quelques animaux qui sont nés chez
Philippe directement vraiment chez lui
quand on voit tous ces animaux dans bah
carrément chez lui on peut se demander
mais pourquoi on les relâche pas tout
simplement dans la nature chez eux quoi
alors il y a plusieurs choses c'est que
déjà si tu relâes dans la nature en
France dans un dans un environnement qui
est pas leur environnement naturel il y
a quand même peu de chance pour qu'ils
survivent parce qu'ils sont pas faits
pour survivre dans ce genre de
d'environnement lui il utilise une
métaphore qui est assez marrante il dit
c'est comme si toi entre lacher en
maillot de bain en pôle Nord tu
survivrais pas 5 minutes bah c'est un
peu pareil et puis il y a le fait que
c'est dangereux tout simplement et puis
ensuite tu as des animaux qui pour la
enfin ces animaux pour la plupart enfin
pour pas mal d'entre eux ils sont nés en
captivité donc du coup ils ont pas
forcément développé les défenses
immunitaires qu's sont censées
développer quand ils sont à l'état
sauvage bah il y a aussi une question
que je me suis posée moi pendant le
tournage et que je lui ai posé c'est que
pourquoi est-ce qu'on renvoie pas tout
simplement ces animaux dans dans le pays
d'où ils viennent en fait c'est des
raisons qui sont un peu plus politiques
c'està-dire que dans un pays qui a déjà
plein de cobras plein de Python plein de
choses comme ça ils sont pas forcément
ils ont pas forcément que ça à faire de
les récupérer et puis ça pose aussi des
questions logistiques et financière
comment est-ce qu'on fait pour les
renvoyer merci beaucoup Clémentine bah
merci à toi j'espère que cet épisode
vous aura intéressé n'hésitez pas à nous
dire ce que vous en avvez pensé en
commentaire et à liker la vidéo ce type
de reportage c'est quelque chose qu'on
retrouvera de temps en temps dans la
grande explication ça me donne un peu
plus de temps pour préparer les sujets
et ça vous permet aussi de voir le
travail d'autres journalistes de brut
sur le terrain toujours sur les animaux
l'environnement la semaine prochaine on
se retrouvera pour un épisode plus
classique à
[Musique]
bientôt